the human immunodeficiency virus
commonly known as HIV is a retrovirus
that causes acquired immunodeficiency
syndrome or AIDS this is a condition
that causes the progressive failure of
the immune system by allowing
life-threatening infections to thrive
recently new gene therapy methods using
HIV have been created to cure cancer
this involves creating modified HIV the
HIV is created by taking out the
proteins that would cause the HIV to
remain harmful when essential protein in
the survival of HIV is the HIV one
matrix protein p17 as it participates in
the early stages of reproduction for the
virus by removing this protein HIV can
no longer successfully reproduce in the
host cell this is an animation of the
p17 protein by modifying the HIV it is
no longer dangerous and can no longer
affect patients as it would if normal
HIV was used SMAW defied HIV can then be
inserted into healthy t-cells which are
white blood cells that are procured from
the patient normally t-cells cannot
detect cancer cells an antigen is
necessary for normal T cells to become
activated the leftover genetic material
from the modified HIV can help these new
tumor and infiltrating lymphocytes or
TILs to easily recognize an antigen
found on cancerous cells this antigen is
a surface protein cd19 the TILs function
as serial killer T cells and target the
cancer cells quickly and effectively
this is an animation of the CV 19
protein and a photo of the TILs locating
and killing the cancerous cells in a
patient once the special T cells are
infused into the blood there is cellular
war the TI ELLs go from one tumor cell
to the next
and kill them eventually the cancer will
be gone though a newly developed
treatment the combination of HIV and
cancer could be the gateway to the cure
for cancer
you